bonjour william maury merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france comment
est-ce que vous accueillez l'annnonce de
gérald darmanin et comment est-ce
qu'elle a été perçu par vos collègues
alors seulement au niveau de la caméra
moi je suis favorable après c'est comme
partout et voilà il ya des pour il ya
des contrôles et bon ben voilà le mes
collègues policiers
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
aujourd'hui avoir tout et tout est
numérique donc voilà on a un temps de
retard sur surtout ça c'est à dire que
là on voit des vidéos diffusées contre
les forces de l'ordre en permanence avec
des montages avec des coupures de vidéos
ça pourra permettre déjà dans un premier
temps de le voir une autre réalité que
celle qui a pu nous être montré là sur
les deux dernières années durant les
manifestations toit de l'interpellation
un peu musclé où nous taxer de le
violences illégitimes ou de bavures
policières
au moins voilà là on pourra montrer
l'envers du décor à mon sens concernant
le matériel on a eu déjà des caméras
traitons avec des autonomies tellement
faible il ne tient pas citer
l'enregistrement calme en couple c'est
justement une autonomie de 4 heures
au final est ce que c'est vraiment utile
de porter ces caméras piétons le
problème c'est que 2 2 à 4 heures sur
une pac oui maintenant qu'ils eurent
12h08
voilà à quel moment à quel moment on va
lui donner mais vraiment rien enregistré
quelque chose ce soir on fait ça soit on
donne une batterie avec une autonomie de
foi sidr mal à la contenir la patrouille
complète soit on donne mais les
les automobiles de 2 à 4 heures et on va
être taxé de de truqueur ou de menteur
voilà patrimoine a pu enregistrer la
totalité des interventions
donc voilà c'est fini à proto quoi comme
ça été mis en place il faut donner aussi
des moyens qu'ils soient mis
correctement plat se mettre les moyens
au collet m à mon sens soit là pour
l'instant on n'a pas la technologie
adaptée aux jardins du crir j'ai pas
trouvé une caméra qui dure de leader
j'ai pas combien de capacités aussi les
autres c'est compliqué on sait que la
prochaine élection présidentielle c'est
dans moins de deux ans est ce que cette
annonce
cette mesure n'est pas purement
politiques est ce que ce n'est pas un
effet d'annoncé justement gérald
darmanin qui tend la main aux policiers
de lons vous en avez dans tous les
secteurs la sécurité on sait que ça peut
être un très long lui au niveau
politique mais je pense que sa femme
avoir le bon sens voilà c'est trop de
policiers sont mis en cause
voilà via les vidéos qu'on peut trouver
sur le net et pour quinze jours actuels
après que ces vidéos lancer le buzz
s'apercevoir qu'il ya d'autres vidéos de
vidéoprotection qu'après exploitation
les policiers ont agi en légitime
défense ce sont en fait qui dérange
c'est que aujourd'hui l'institution
police est tellement malmené pour tout
et n'importe quoi c'est qu'une fois
qu'on donne un outil
voilà pour montrer la réalité parce que
voilà c'est dit qu'il fallait savoir
aussi très en demande au ministre de
pouvoir diffuser certaines vidéos
si on tire on laisse plus qu'aux
citoyens exactement ce qu'on vit au
quotidien
oh ben non pas qu'on cherche le raid les
chaumières mais jusqu'au cou rentré un
petit peu le quotidien la police y est
mais sans son cadet d'image sans
enjoliver un peu les situations sans
voilà justement près ce qui se passe sur
le terrain parce que outre été achetés
quotidiennement
voilà à bora bora un bouton qui vidéo je
pense que c'est le super que ce soit au
niveau
voilà le grand public au niveau
judiciaire ça permettra à beaucoup de
choses
merci où il est mort et d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire général d'options nuit
officier de police judiciaire